[Musique]
bonsoir bonsoir à tous bienvenue dans ça
vous regarde à la une ce soir le
terrorisme islamiste frappe à nouveau le
pays moins de deux semaines après la
décapitation du professeur samuel pâtit
une attaque s'est produite ce matin à
nice attaque à l'armé blanche au sein de
la basilique notre-dame en plein centre
ville
trois morts que doit être la riposte
doit-on durcir notre arsenal judiciaire
adaptée l'état de droit est ce la
solution c'est le thème de notre grand
débat ce soir une attaque terroriste qui
intervient alors que le pays s'apprête à
se re confiné leur confinement commence
ce soir à minuit l'assemblée nationale a
adopté très largement un vote symbolique
ce matin sans valeur contraignante
les oppositions dénonce une démocratie
en trompe l'oeil on en parlera aussi ce
soir et puis pour évoquer tous ces
sujets dans le fauteuil du grand témoin
un journaliste ce soir il publie avec
michèle cotta le brun et le rouge
scénario thriller à suspense dans lequel
il met en scène une candidate d'extrême
droite qui prend le pouvoir en 2025
impossible au contraire totalement
plausible nous poserons la question à
robert namias invité fil rouge ce soir
voilà donc pour le programme c'est parti
hashtag sévère pour réagir tout de suite
le grand lyon
[Musique]
et bienvenue à vous chers
téléspectateurs bonsoir robert namias
bonjour vous êtes masqué je le précise
ce soir c'est le protocole sanitaire de
l'assemblée nationale qui a été durcie
merci de jouer le jeu dans cette
émission en direct et merci d'être avec
nous en cette journée de la sente pour
le pays vous êtes journaliste longtemps
grandes voix d'europe un ancien patron
de l'info à tf1 et vous signez avec
michèle cotta le brun et le rouge après
fake news c'est toujours chez robert
laffont n'en dira un mot vous dirais
surtout si dans ce contexte éprouvant
pour tout le monde et bien le réel ne
rattrape pas votre fiction le réel vous
l'avez évidemment imaginer compris c'est
à nouveau cet attentat un nouvel
attentat islamiste à nice nice qui est à
nouveau frappé cette fois c'est la
basilique notre dame en plein
centre-ville trois morts deux femmes et
un homme bonsoir yale brune peavey
bonsoir on va en parler avec vous vous
êtes député en marche des yvelines
présidente de la commission des lois à
l'assemblée nationale vous dialoguerait
ce soir avec laurent jacobellis bonsoir
vous êtes porte parole du rassemblement
national pierre connais ça va nous
rejoindre dans quelques instants il est
bloqué dans les bouchons c'est leur
confinement une de ses conséquences
en ile de france ce soir il est ancien
haut fonctionnaire au ministère de la
défense et spécialiste des questions
liées à la radicalisation je vous donne
la parole dans un instant mais d'abord
les faits et toutes les réactions
politiques
on voit cela avec clément pernot
emmanuel macron à la rencontre des
policiers de nice cet après midi
quelques heures après l'attentât le
président prend la parole si nous sommes
attaqués
une fois encore c'est pour les valeurs
qui sont les nôtres pour notre goût de
la liberté pour cette possibilité sur
notre sol de croire librement et de ne
céder à aucun esprit de terreur et je le
dis avec beaucoup de clarté une fois
encore aujourd'hui nous ne céderons rien
il est 9h ce matin quand la taca lieu à
l'intérieur puis autour de la basilique
notre dame de l'assomption à nice un
homme s'en prend sauvagement à plusieurs
personnes avec une arme blanche en
criant allah ouakbar deux femmes et un
homme trouve la mort dans cet attentat
l'auteur lui est blessé par balle et
interpellé
selon les premiers éléments de l'enquète
il s'agit d'un tunisien de 21 ans
récemment arrivés en europe par l'amp et
12 ha le parc national antiterroriste se
saisit de l'enquète et le plan
vigipirate est relevée au niveau urgence
attentats partout en france
moins d'une heure après l'attaqué jean
castex vient de terminer à l'assemblée
sa déclaration sur les nouvelles mesures
sanitaires
il descend du pupitre en bas de
l'escalier il est informé sur la
situation à nice il remonte alors et
échangent quelques mots avec le
président de l'assemblée nationale
richard ferrand prend ensuite la parole
nous venons d'apprendre à l'instant
pendant que s'est exprimé le premier
ministre qu'un attentat d'une gravité
extrême s'est produit à nice je vous
demande dans ces circonstances tragiques
d'observer une minute de silence en
solidarité à l'égard de la ou des
victimes
évidemment de l'ensemble de ses proches
la séance est interrompue dans la foulée
les députés sont sous le choc
nous sommes très secoué pour plein de
raisons
le lieu et la foi catholique
l'accumulation d'événements horrible qui
nous perturbe tous et nous font nous
interroger sur ce que va être notre vie
et collectif demain beaucoup de
tristesse aussi beaucoup de colère j'ai
mal pour la france aujourd'hui je pense
à tous les français qui voient comme cet
attentat de manière horrible je pense
bien sûr aussi à tous les pratiquants
catholiques à la veille de la toussaint
mais derrière l'émotion plusieurs
députés exigent très vite des actes du
gouvernement
nous pensons surtout à agir car il faut
agir maintenant je ne sais pas combien
d'attentats il sera nécessaire pour que
le gouvernement prenne conscience que
nous avons besoin de nous doter d'une
législation de guerre pour répondre à la
guerre qu'ils aient mené la majorité
elle a appelé à l'unité face à la menace
terroriste
on va évidemment révoquer les réponses
possible souhaitable mais d'abord votre
réaction
vous étiez dans l'hémicycle également ce
matin quand vous avez appris tout à fait
gt gt dans l'hémicycle nous sommes tous
stupéfaits
on en a marre en a marre de faire des
minutes de silence dans l'hémicycle mois
voilà depuis depuis 2010 est ça n'est
malheureusement pas la première
c'est à chaque fois trajets qu on pense
aux familles on pense aux victimes
on pense aussi à nos forces de l'ordre
qui à chaque fois interviennent dans des
conditions extrêmement difficiles
elle me disait supportable ces attaques
pour les français comment comment vous
vous allez faire pour éviter que la peur
ne gagne tout le pays la panique aussi
je pense qu'il faut que les responsables
politiques que nous sommes de tout bord
il faut que nous ayons un discours
extrêmement responsable extrêmement
vigilant extrêmement fermes sur ce que
nous souhaitons faire il faut nommer les
choses il faut agir
il ne faut pas diviser il ne faut pas
polémiquer ces sujets sont trop graves
et encore une fois il s'agit de la
sécurité de nos concitoyens
et ça n'est pas là le temps des
polémiques ou c'est le temps de l'action
c'est le temps de l'action résolue
c'est ce que nous faisons depuis 2007 je
pense que c'est ce que faisait avant les
autres gouvernements c'est ce que nous
devons faire dans une optique république
et à voyez venir sur le national laurent
jacot bel et emmanuel macron on a appelé
à l'unité de tous styles compter sur
votre parti national oui je pense que
tous les français peuvent compter sur
notre parti nous l'unité oui mais
l'unité ne veut pas dire la fin de
l'opposition l'unité ne veut pas dire
que nous ne pouvons pas être force de
proposition et l'unité ne veut pas dire
que nous ne pouvons pas souligné un
certain nombre de défaillances dans le
système et regretté que toutes les
semaines maintenant même plusieurs fois
par jour comme aujourd'hui il y ait des
attentats en france
tout cela n'est plus possible alors
j'entends bien ces grands appels à
l'unité j'entends bien ces minutes du
silence j'entends bien ses mots de
compassion et c'est un ciment ou les
partages nationale nécessaire et
subtilement nationale il faut le
protéger il faut que notre nation
n'explose pas il faut que nos valeurs
soient maintenues nos valeurs elles sont
fondamentales c'est la liberté de la
presse si on a bien vu il ya quelques
semaines que les terroristes voulaient
attaquer la liberté de la presse c'est
l'enseignement qui permet à tous les
citoyens de s'élever à tout enfant de
france de devenir ce dont il a rêvé cet
enseignement on a bien vu aussi qu'ils
avaient été attaqués et puis c est une
civilisation de baser sur la chrétienté
la france et on voit bien aujourd'hui
que c'est cette base civilisationnel
aussi qui a été attaqué donc oui il faut
protéger la france mais pour ça il faut
s'armer
psychologiquement il faut s'armer aussi
légalement nous en parlerons
cent cinquante et une mosquée où son
prêt chez où sont tenus par dont des
paroles de haine
chaque semaine le gouvernement actuel en
affaires mais que vite c'est mieux que
rien ça va dans la bonne direction a
parlé il ya beaucoup à faire va parler
des s'il s'agira agir
nous serons là d'allumer des bougies
nous estimons que c'est pas suffi la
politique de la bougie ça suffit robert
namias
c'est incroyable on se disait ça fait
très longtemps que la france n'a pas
traversé un tel moment d'épreuve il ya
évidemment la crise sanitaire mais il ya
une forme de vague d'attentats auxquels
le pays est confronté
oui mais monsieur parlait de nos valeurs
je pense que ce qui se passe c'est
précisément l'effet pervers tragiquement
pervers du fait que l'on tient à ces
valeurs qui sont des valeurs qui sont
communes à l'ensemble de la communauté
nationale mais qui ne sont pas communes
à l'ensemble de la communauté
internationale bien de là même la
laïcité nous avons nous une pratique et
une conception
si vous voulez une conception une
pratique de la laïcité qui est quasiment
unique au monde
dans son rapport avec les religions les
rôles à l'international
absolument du coup il se passe quelque
chose qui est tout à fait nouveau avec
ce terrorisme
on pourrait appeler de la quatrième
génération qui ce qui est ce terrorisme
venu de nulle part et de partout mais
qui est aujourd'hui alimenté par un
certain nombre de pays qui en tant que
pays refuse nos valeurs eh bien on voit
bien que par exemple ce qui se passe
depuis un certain nombre de semaines en
france est née mécaniquement alimenté
par erdogan
les propos d'erdogan l'appel à une forme
de fatwa mais qui est relayé également
par on le voit l'ancien premier ministre
malaisien l'actuel ministre des affaires
étrangères pakistanais
et puis un certain nombre de pays on
pense au qatar on pense à l'arabie
saoudite qui jouent des rôles
extrêmement ambigu et surtout à
l'ensemble des pays musulmans
qui finalement se disent mais on peut
pas être complètement sur cette affaire
de l'islam complètement en arrière de la
main et donc on est dans une situation
vous me posiez la question y at il des
précédents je dirais avec cette forme de
terrorisme et dans cette situation
internationale
non il n'y a pas de précédent elle brûle
depuis veille et un contexte
géopolitique
évidemment on va revenir sur les
caricatures on va parler des réponses
mais il yad'autres yad'autres aux
attentes a enfin en tout cas il ya jada
aujourd'hui arabie saoudite
un vigile du consulat français blessé au
couteau sartrouville
un homme a été interpellé à proximité
d'une église vous avez des informations
oui parce que c'est ma circonscription
et à priori c'était à des matériaux et
maintenant ça ne serait pas terrorisme
et il ya eu une levée de doute qui
montre que nos services et nos services
sur le territoire agissent lyon un
islamiste radical armé d'un couteau
interpellé aujourd'hui qu'est ce qui se
passe comment comment vous comprenez ce
qui se passe mais on sent bien qu'ils à
ce climat qui est extrêmement paradoxal
parce que finalement vous parliez de la
laïcité qui est quelque chose d'unique
au monde
la laïcité c'est le fait pour tout
citoyen en france de pouvoir vivre sa
croyance ou sa non croyance et je crois
que les musulmans en france et ils sont
des millions de compatriotes vivent de
façon extrêmement paisible et
extrêmement sereine leur foi dans le
respect des valeurs de la république et
aujourd'hui ça se retourne complètement
contre nos finalement on a des pays tels
que la turquie le qatar qui viennent
nous dire que les musulmans en france ne
pourrait pas vivre leur foi
ça n'est complètement
c'est complètement inexacte cette
inacceptable d'entendre ça c'est ce
qu'ont ils sombrent établir la vérité
les musulmans aujourd'hui en france
peuvent vivre leur foi à partir du
moment où ils respectent les valeurs de
la république et c'est l'immense
majorité de nos compatriotes faut
évidemment il ne faut pas de mal garé
c'est important parce que il ne faut pas
rentrer dans une espèce de d'opposition
et de guerre civile et d'un malgache
parce que je pense que ce serait
extrêmement grave à revenir sur la
liberté d'expression le droit au
blasphème qui est spécifique à notre
pays tout à l'heure avec stéphane
blakowski dans sa chronique première
réponse d'un conseil de défense de marc
inquiets se tenir après ce qui s'est
passé à nice première réponse sentinelle
avec le déploiement de 3000 à 7,2 passes
de se passer de 3000 à 7000 militaires
pour l'opération de ces militaires qui
vont maintenant surveiller
on s'en souvient après 2015 les écoles
et les lieux de culte dans le pays
est-ce que c'est suffisant bien sûr que
non c'est utile bien sûr et je tiens
comme vous l'avez fait madame la députée
a salué le travail de nos militaires de
sentinelle mais aussi des forces de
l'ordre qui ont qui sont intervenus
aujourd'hui à nice de manière assez
assez brillante mais il faut régler le
mal profond
nous sommes en guerre des gens ont
déclaré la guerre à notre civilisation
parce que nous sommes ils viennent nous
tuer chez nous face à cela il faut
réagir fortement il faut nommer les
choses mais les choses n'ont pas de
législation de guerre c'est ce que
défend marine le pen jantes réellement
sais quoi parce qu'aujourd'hui contre le
terrorisme il ya des tribunaux
d'exception il ya des gardes à vue qui
durent plus longtemps
on est déjà dans un droit d'exception à
sauter or la seule question qu'on doit
se poser c'est est-ce que ça marche
apparemment non non pour deux raisons la
première c'est que la justice
malheureusement parfois est un peu
laxiste même face au terrorisme
j'aurai un seul exemple le pakistanais
qui a commis l'attentât proche des les
anciens locaux de charlie hebdo était un
faux mineurs isolés
le département qui avait en charge ce
faux mineurs isolés avaient des doutes
et quand on le voit évidemment on a des
doutes il est évidemment pas mineur ils
voulaient procéder à des tests osseux
c'est la justice qui a refusé or si on
avait fait les choses dans l'ordre
si on avait appliqué les textes comme le
conseil départemental pouvait le faire
cet individu n'avait plus rien à faire
sur le sol mesure d'injustice de la
justice constitutionnelle de la justice
administrative aujourd'hui face au
terrorisme
un mur je ne sais pas mais il y à des
lenteurs en tout cas qui font qu'on ne
peut pas agir aujourd'hui on nous
explique que les 4000 fichier s est
rangée fichier s pour risques de
radicalisation et bien tous ne peuvent
pas être expulsés du territoire français
ce n'est pas normal
on nous explique qu'il est difficile de
des deux firmes et les 150 mosquées
salafistes où l'on explique qu'il faut
détruire l'occident que la femme doit
être soumise que louise homosexuels
doivent être lynché et bien il faut les
fermer de manière urgente et si pour ça
il faut une législation d'exception
et on la remplace le coeur du sujet et
lebron peavey vous souvenez vous aviez
défendu un texte qui avait été adoptée à
l'unanimité sur le suivi des détenus
radicaliser à leur sortie de prison
et c'est juste constitutionnel qui
finalement lavé censuré qu'est ce que
vous répondez au fond à l'argument du
rassemblement national l'état de droit
il faut le muscler face à cette menace
terroriste c'est ce que nous faisons
continuellement depuis charlie nous
avons adopté au fur et à mesure des
années des lois d'exception vous l'avez
rappelé nous avons rallongé les gardes à
vue nous avons pré pré pré pré vu des
juridictions d'exception et des cours
d'assises spéciale nous avons muscler
les délits et avec la création du délit
d'association malfait de malfaiteurs en
vue d'une entreprise terroriste
donc la législation elle s'est adaptée
au fur et à mesure elle s'est renforcée
sur le droit d'asile par exemple les
recours qui freine les expulsions sur
certains recours contre la fermeture de
mosquées ou des fermetures des
associations et médias il faut aller
plus loin au contraire attention l'état
de droit doit rester l'état de droit
sinon c'est aller sur le terrain de mes
terroriste que de changer il faut
surtout pas confondre on parle on parle
de terroristes on parle pas de droit
d'asile
on parle de ouais c'est pas la même
chose excusez moi tu pars fois ci du
matin mais parfois si mais vous savez
vous me faites penser j'ai relu référé
saman réflexions sur la question juive
de jean paul sartre et tout au début de
son livre il parle d'une femme dont la
fourrure à brûler chez un fourreur juif
je sais pas si ça vous dit quelque chose
et la dame commence à partir dans une
diatribe antisémite
elle ne s'en prend pas aux fourrure elle
s'en prend pas aux vieux fourrure c'est
le fourreur parce qu'il est juif
mais là c'est pareil c'est pas parce que
la mèche terminer mon propos il s'est
continuée binger en continu et la
fidélisation des oscillations et la
moins chère vous expliquer ainsi yves
assumer envers le premier parti
d'opposition
vous êtes c'est que les meetings ne
comptait pas du tout c'est pas du tout
ce que j'entendais du tout cette année
les angles quand par exemple quelqu'un
s'il vous plaît vous me laissez parler
et après vous pourrez me répond non
voilà si vous aimez vous parlez vous
verriez où je veux en venir vous exprime
si vous avez quelqu'un qui commet un vol
c'est pas parce que c'est pas parce
qu'il est si l'étranger et voleurs le
point c'est que les voleurs il est pas
voleur parce qu'il est étranger là nous
pouvons avoir parfois des auteurs
d'attentats qui sont étrangers qui sont
demandeurs d'asile aucun lien envoyé mes
grassley est le terreau est
malheureusement mal caïmans
malheureusement je voudrais terminer ma
phrase dans les derniers attentats qui
ont été commis en france ces derniers
attentats ont été commis en majorité par
des personnes qui sont de nationalité
française
alors ça ne vous convient pas mais c'est
un fait et dont vous vouliez obstinément
ville le terrorisme avec l'immigration
vie serait-elle une planète la dot
le pakistanais mineurs isolés d'il ya un
mois
pakistanais demandeurs d'asile mineurs
isolés rien des faits rohfritsch parce
qu'ils les pakistanais cette chaîne le
tchétchène bandits les plus jeunes et
pakistanais moi aussi je vais terminer
mon raisonnement si ça vous ennuie pas
le tchétchène qui a décapité un
professeur français tchétchène ses
parents étaient déboutées du droit
d'asile avant qu'un juge on en revient
là n'oblige la france à le recevoir
actuellement selon les premiers éléments
de l'enquète ce qu'on sait aussi c'est
que la personne qui ait fait cette
chemise 1 à l'aller à migrants
clandestins leur arrivée par l'onp et du
zares est toute la question très
simplement à lyon aujourd'hui ray ne
sont pas des terroristes est évidemment
là dessus les haies qui a dit ça
simplement en laissant la porte ouverte
à une immigration massive et incontrôlée
passe par ce flux des gens mal
intentionnés
le problème et je terminerai ce
raisonnement qui est très important
parce que vous dites pas d'amalgamé vous
les appliquer à nous le problème c'est
qu'en changeant de mode d'immigration
aujourd'hui ne la contrôle plus arrivent
en france des gens qui ne viennent pas
pour l'amour de la france
ils viennent pas pour l'amour de sa
langue sa culture qui viennent pour
d'autres raisons qui ne s'assimile pas
la machine à assimiler et cassé sacré du
communautarisme qui est le terreau
favori favori de l'islamisation
il faut donc oui
avoir une politique d'immigration
beaucoup plus restrictive quatre
attentats
quatre migrants madame qui n'avaient
rien à faire sur le sol national n'est
pas le voir si la vérité le
rassemblement national n'est pas le seul
à considérer que l'immigration c'est un
peu l'angle mort du discours notamment
d' emmanuel macron sur sur les
séparatismes les républicains eric
ciotti par exemple je pense la même
chose
c'est une question qui est en train de
se voit là d'évoluer on le sent bien
dans le débat il faut s'en saisir c'est
une question centrale dans le débat
politique et qui sera central
incontestablement dans le débat
politique de la prochaine présidentielle
pour autant honnêtement la question du
terrorisme n'est pas la question de
l'immigration
pour une raison simple et notamment ce
terrorisme qu'on peut appeler de la
quatrième génération qui est un
terrorisme individuel qui est le
résultat est le produit de gens qui se
radicalise et on voit bien qu'il ya
autant de france est vraiment de
natalité française voire qui ne sont
peut-être même pas à l'origine musulmans
mais qui se sont convertis à l'islam qui
se radicalise et c'est ce terrorisme là
qui est le plus difficile aujourd'hui à
tenter de combattre parce que il est
nulle part il n'est pas fiché ce
terrorisme là il n'est même pas fichés s
pour l'essentiel à la limite des
clandestins des immigrés ont fini par
les repérer et on peut les suivre
le terrorisme de la conversion de
français c'est un terrorisme terrible et
nous sommes actuellement dans cette
situation pas du tout ce parti
reconnaissaient à pardonnez moi je vais
c'est la réalité de ce qu'on appelle
aujourd'hui le plateau de pierre conesa
merci d'être avec nous on vous pardonne
vous étiez dans les bouchons qui sont
importants ce soir avec ce reconfirme
ans qui a dû à à minuit qui sera en
vigueur à minuit
quelle lecture vous faites de ce qui
s'est passé a nice on a évoqué un
contexte géopolitique après la
publication des caricatures dont on nous
parle de cette date du 29 octobre la
date anniversaire de la naissance du
prophète est ce que ça ça peut jouer
comment comment vous voyez ce qui s'est
joué moi ce qui me frappe si vous voulez
mais c'est une remarque un peu accidenté
vous savez on accuse toujours dès qu'on
parle de la question de l'islam radical
du jihadisme etc
on vous dit fait pas d'album amalgame or
vous remarquerez que la réaction des
pays musulmans aujourd'hui font eux
mêmes le mâle gamme c'est à dire quelles
que soient les victimes qu'on subisse en
france à partir du moment où on parle de
l'islam ils vous disent attention
attention vous êtes entraînés mais c'est
eux qui se solidarisent avec les
terroristes aujourd'hui
voyez le truc on a quand même des morts
d'un côté et puis on a des gens qui vous
critiquent la caricature du prophète
il ya une espèce de balance qui est
devenu totalement déséquilibrée c'est à
dire qu'on a à faire aujourd'hui à des
pays notamment des régimes qui rompent
qui manque de légitimité politique et
qu'ils vont faire de l'islamisme et ils
se rendent pas compte que c'est eux qui
font de l'amalgamme bon ça c'est une
remarque incidente la remarque si vous
voulez propres et d'attentats ont fait
face il y en aura d'autres pour moi
c'est une troisième génération
d'attentats si vous avez eu si vous
voulez les attentats qu'on a connu avec
des chants fin vous l'avez probablement
10 dont je vais pas insister là-dessus
le deuxième j'ai pas rêver 4e bon vous
voyez on a besoin de plus que moi mais
cette vague là s'il voulait associer
deux caractéristiques on la connaît avec
mila on l'a connu avec samuel vaty on la
connaît aujourd'hui c'est à dire vous
avez un fait les générateurs peu importe
qu'ils soient vrais ou pas rappelez vous
la faire se mêlent pâtit c'est la jeune
fille qui ment à son père mais son père
s'enflamme immédiatement il est connu
comme un individu un activisme et y met
tout de suite dans le coup un faiseur
d'opinion un agitateur qui est l'imam
zekraoui et ensuite ça va s'enflammer
sur le réseau etc jusqu'à la désignation
le ciblage de lynchage la chasse en
meute et c'est pour ce qui concerne nice
pour l'instant on n'a pas ce continue
attendu justement ces islamistes
jusqu'au succès l'aja l'a donc c'est
pour ça que je le dis parce que si vous
voulez on n'a pas grand chose à dire sur
nice mais simplement on a le même
phénomène générateur c'est-à-dire un
individu qu'il très difficile de cibler
s et qui d'un seul coup va se révéler
être l'exécutant d'une espèce
d'instruction générique si vous voulez
qui est porté par des de multiples
acteurs et et ça ça rend la police et la
justice totalement désarmé c'est à dire
ça passe au dessous des radars comment
voulez-vous par exemple pour suivre les
trente mille tweets qui menace de mort
les jeunes me l'a pas possible on a
réussi à trois condamnations sur 30000
c'est quand même faible et toujours la
question de
réussir l'exécution l'exécution des
décisions
je voudrais qu'on aborde la question des
caricatures parce que tout a changé
depuis le discours du président la
république
ça n'est pas une habitude de vous
retrouver par skype
stéphane stéphane blakowski vous êtes
chez vous vous êtes très bien mais on va
quand même avoir droit votre biais
d'actu si j'ai bien compris tout ce
qu'on soit environ
si j'ai bien compris ce soir stéphane
blakowski et bien si j'ai bien compris
myriam malgré les attentats islamistes
qui se multiplient de notre pays il est
hors de question de renoncer à notre
liberté d'expression est un point sur
lequel le président macron a été
extrêmement clair lors de l'hommage
qu'il a rendue à sa mère pattie dans la
cour de la sorbonne c'est l'occasion de
leur écoute et nous défendrons la
liberté que vous enseignez c'est bien et
nous porterons haut la laïcité
nous ne renoncerons pas aux caricatures
au dessin même si d'autres reculs
et pour une fois la classe politique est
unanime sur cette question des
caricatures ou presque on doit rien
céder à la liberté d'expression
c'est vrai que myriam ya unanimité sur
cette carte aujourd'hui la liberté
d'expression d'ap a vu effectivement une
petite polémique cette semaine puisque
mardi bruno retailleau était invité sur
rtl et on lui a posé la question lui a
demandé monsieur retailleau est ce que
vous trouvez que c'est une bonne idée de
montrer les caricatures de mahomet est
pour toutes les écoles à la rentrée
alors on écoute un extrait que sa
réponse ces caricatures là on doit
pouvoir les faire dans la presse les
distribuer de façon massive
je pense qu'il faut aussi être prudent
pas tellement pour craindre un certain
nombre de réactions mais je pense moi je
suis pour une forme de respect
alors forcément ça paraît contradictoire
parce que des clairac et sûrs
respectueux blocks vous laissez plus des
caricatures dont évidemment gérald
darmanin immédiatement pris à partie
monsieur retailleau lui demandant de
retirer ses propos
évidemment 200 côté bruno retailleau on
m'a mal compris d'ailleurs mettre les
choses au clair il a publié un tweet on
ne peut plus clair en disant eux mêmes
ou élire personne n'a le droit de
remettre en cause la liberté
plus adroits nature en france donc la
polémique est close
alors oui cette politique elle est close
myriam mais ces dames l'occasion de
rappeler que le droit à la carac la part
dont le droit à la caricature n'a pas
toujours été unanimement défendue par la
classe politique
souvenez vous en février 2006 et ce mois
là que charlie hebdo a publié son fameux
numéro avec des caricatures du prophète
et c'était une de cadu c'est dur d'être
aimé par des cons et bien à l'époque le
président de la république jacques
chirac avait condamné cette initiative
de charlie hebdo on peut regarder sur le
site de l'église et son discours y est
toujours voilà ce qu'on disait chirac
la liberté d'expression doit s'exercer
dans un esprit de responsabilité
je condamne les provocations
susceptibles d'attiser les passions que
charlie hebdo a longtemps été seul pas
toujours soutenu par les pouvoirs
publics
loin de la loi à myriam parce que en
fait ils ont à nouveau publié des
caricatures en 2012
il y avait eu 1 300 en 2006 qui sont
gagnés dont vous avez le droit de le
faire en 2012 il republier ces
caricatures
cette fois ci c'est la gauche qui est au
pouvoir et misait des affaires
étrangères c'est fabuleux qu'est ce
qu'il dit à ce moment là est-ce que
c'est pertinent et intelligente dans ce
cadre-là en parlions juste avant de
venir de mettre un peu d'huile sur le
feu la france et non
mais il n'était pas le seul salut ça
dénoncé la lys est de charlie par
exemple à l'ump à droite voilà ce que
rachida dati grillé elle trouvait que
charlie a day tort parce que c'était un
coït orial elle n'était pas non plus la
seule il y avait aussi ouais on voit la
réaction et le rachat d'ati même au
front national s'appelle front national
à l'époque un député du front national
en l'occurrence gilbert collard trouvait
que jarry n'aurais pas dû faire ça car
c'était une opération commerciale voyez
myriam une bonne partie de la classe
politique a longtemps demandé à charlie
hebdo de ne pas publier de caricatures
pour éviter de provoquer des réactions
violentes contre la france ou contre les
français alors aujourd'hui encore on
pourrait se poser la question faut-il
renoncer aux caricatures pour éviter les
représailles
la seule question c'est est-ce que cette
question se pose encore aujourd'hui se
pose encore aujourd'hui c'est fini ça y
est on peut dire autour de cette table
du rassemblement national à la
république en marche
en passant par la gauche et la droite ça
y est en france on va défendre ce
combat-là de la liberté d'expression
d'une robe la semaine alors c'est pas ça
y est quand même faut pas exagérer je
pense qu'à la fin ce jour là la région
défendre la liberté d'expression ne se
négocie pas et finalement on n'a même
pas aller à commenter ces caricatures
ils font bien ce qu'ils veulent ils
publient bien ce qu'ils veulent et même
dans ce contexte bien chez attentats
mais maintenant son nom pierre connais
ça et qu'on voit qu'il ya des mouvements
dans d'autres pays qui vont continuer à
brûler le drapeau français et à nous
intimider mais j'allais même vous dire
surtout dans ce contexte là il ne faut
pas que nous appliquions il ne faut pas
que nous appliquions notre nos règles de
l'état de droit on en parlait tout à
l'heure il ne faut pas que nous
habitions nos valeurs se rend quoi nous
croyants ce qui fait que nous sommes la
france grand jacques aubé lis jamais on
n'empêchera on ne devra empêcher un
caricaturiste ou un journaliste de dire
ou de dessiner ce qu'il veut dans les
limites de la loi c'est donc pas
d'incitation à la haine
évidemment mais c'est allé là même un
dans votre parti c'était pas si évident
il ya quelques mois il a dit ce colloque
c'est une opération commerciale
bon ça veut pas dire qu il lui
interdisait mais vous savez même si
imaginons que pour apaiser les esprits
on cédait ça ne suffirait pas parce que
depuis des années on a cédé surtout on a
cédé sur le voile il a fallu des
horaires séparés en piscine on a cédé
sur les horaires séparés en piscine il a
fallu des menus différentiel à la
cantine on a cédé sur les menus
diferencias la cantine vous savez c'est
une technique d'avancé petit pas par
petit pas obscurantisme contre
république française et on a laissé trop
longtemps
l'obscurantisme avancer maintenant il
faut dire c'est qu'il ya beaucoup de
professeurs qui vont non mais moi je
crois que le débat sur liberté
d'expression qui est vraiment l'une des
valeurs là aussi fondamental de notre
république et et est de la france avec
la laïcité comme on lisait tout à
l'heure et quand même un peu et moi j'en
suis un petit peu jeune et même
intellectuellement si vous voulez
faussée par le fait qu' on a tous
focalisés sur les caricatures de mahomet
publiées par charlie hebdo c'est le
principe même de la liberté totale de
dire et de dire à travers des
caricatures qui doit être mise en avant
y compris notamment dans les classes en
particulier dans les cas où
effectivement on sait bien qu'il y a un
problème avec toute une partie de dans
certaines banlieues etc de la population
scolaire qui peut être portée sauf que
si on est et on l'a on ne l'a pas
beaucoup dit j'ai entendu ici et là mais
tellement peu le principe de la
caricature c'est de dire on caricature
tout et tout le monde et on peut ne pas
être d'accord on peut trouver ça
vulgaire
on peut même détester mais on doit
laisser faire les caricatures anti anti
juifs contre les juifs se moquant des
juifs ont été extrêmement nombreuses non
seulement sur charlie hebdo meilleur les
caricatures contre les chrétiens contre
les catholiques contre le pape et c'est
donc il faut replacer cela dans un
contexte d'ensemble et moi ce qui me
gêne politiquement et intellectuellement
c'est que on a accepté soi même nous
mêmes de se focaliser complètement sur
les caricatures de ma mère la france
et elle soutenu dans ce combat là et je
reviens une minute sur ce que disait
monsieur namias est le meilleur moyen de
décrisper la situation c'est de montrer
des collections de charlie hebdo vos
chiens vieux lecteur donc vous avez
effectivement des critiques des juifs
des chrétiens des musulmans etc de façon
à ce qu'on ne sorte les musulmans de
cette idée qui est très importante c'est
à dire la victimologie
il se considère comme victime
systématiquement et c'est comme ça
qu'ils inversent la charge de la preuve
puisque quand il faut un assassinat il
explique que c'est de la faute de la
france moi donc ça si vous voulez sortir
de cette crispation on verra à ce moment
là comment des délais précis mais le
problème va beaucoup plus loin dans les
écoles c'est à dire que vous avez des
parents qu'ils qui est comment dire
qu'ils contestent la capacité du prof a
enseigné l'histoire de l'islam parce
qu'il n'est pas musulman de même que
vous avez à l'enclos des résultats qui
ne veulent pas entendre des cours
d'arabe pour endiguer par quelqu'un qui
n'est pas musulman donc on est sur une
respect ce2 de frontières si vous voulez
qui est totalement flou et qui se
déplace pas d'une génération la lutte
contre l'islamisme
ça ne se fera pas du jour au lendemain
mais cela dit sa venue à cheval c'est le
premier à avoir parlé du salafisme et il
est un rail été trahi par sa classe son
parti politique
donc je veux dire quand est ce qu'on va
enfin s'arrêter de penser à rien je
voudrais terminer ce débat qui s'achève
malheureusement il ya un conseil de
défense demain pour l'instant ce qu'on
sait c'est qu'on monte le niveau de
sentinelle avec 7000 militaires dont les
lieux de culte et les écoles qu'est ce
que vous vous attendez à ce que les élus
mais sur les experts de ce conseil de
défense quelles nouvelles mesures qui
n'ont pas déjà été annoncées doivent
être prises
laurent jacot bd vous répondre après
nous attendons que le gouvernement
prenne des mesures claires et pas
seulement des paroles c'est à dire avec
des actes je le répète les fichiers est
étranger dehors les mosquées salafistes
doivent être fermées c'est absolument
important il faut renforcer nos services
de renseignement intérieur qui depuis
sarkozy 2008 ont eu beaucoup de
désorganisation même si ça s'améliore
et puis il faut nommer les choses oui
l'immigration est un problème
et oui le terrorisme que nous vivons
dans 100% des cas est directement liée à
l'immigration et reconnaissent à demain
qu'est-ce qu'il faut dire qu'est ce
qu'il faut faire
moi j'ai pas sûr super convaincu qu'il
fallait inventer quelque chose de
nouveau les lois existent il faut les
appliquer bon tout à coup vous avez amis
intérieur qui découvre sur son bureau de
131 cas de gens qui expulsables qu'est
ce qui faisait jusque là est-ce qu'ils
étaient couverts de poussière jeu c'est
pas bon ça c'est par choix de la
deuxième chose c'est qu'effectivement
moi ce qui me frappe c'est l'intégration
des musulmans en france on est obligé de
se focaliser sur les salafistes mais on
met tous dans notre environnement qui
est un député qui est chef d'entreprise
qui a un banquier et donc c'est cela
qu'il faut mettre en avant pour dire
mais c'est pas vrai quand on nous accuse
de fées l'islamophobie c'est évidemment
un renversement de la charge de la
preuve défense qui va vous êtes la seule
députée sur ce plateau vous voulez
renforcer l'arsenal cette île on
continue on le renforce
mois après mois la semaine prochaine on
examinera en commission des lois une loi
très importante sur le continuum de
sécurité qui va renforcer les polices
municipales et on voit que la police
municipale un rôle et ça joue un rôle
essentiel à nice donc il faut continuer
la loi séparatisme qui va pouvoir nous
aider à lutter contre notamment les
financements étrangers etc
donc ça aussi c'est des choses qui sont
extrêmement importantes donc la loi on
peut toujours la renforcer et il faut la
regarder
après il faut réorganiser et on continue
à le faire beaucoup d'argent beaucoup de
moyens sur nos services mais on le fait
on a doublé les effectifs de nos
services au t3 en tout à fait dans mes
donc nous continuons d'un tacle al assad
et là ils vont continuer merci beaucoup
merci d'être venu sur le plateau dès le
cp on va parler un petit peu de vous à
présent robert namias on va surtout
parler de votre livre je le disais qu'il
prend à la lumière de tous ces
événements horribles un relief
particulier
de l'info au roman alors le brun et le
rouge c'est chez robert laffont s'est à
nouveau écrit ou coécrit avec votre
complice la journaliste politique
michèle cotta que connaît c'est
évidemment très bien les les français
c'est un thriller
en fait je vous aurais bien longuement
fait raconter votre intrigue mais c'est
pas vraiment ça que j'ai envie de vous
demander parce que au fond cette jeune
femme d'extrême droite qui arrive au
pouvoir en 2025 grâce à une alliance
avec l'extrême gauche mais surtout grâce
ou à cause d'un assassinat d'un attentat
tout ça c'est une mise en garde que vous
écrivez c'est une mise en garde
oui parfois d'aller vite en fait
objectivement d'abord c'est un vrai
polar dont qui se lit comme un polar
mais qui prennent un relief particulier
dans une journée comme un jardin où on a
choisi la forme du polar comme
d'ailleurs dans notre pression nos
romans parce que je pense que c'est plus
accessible plus facile et ça nous permet
surtout de dire des choses auxquelles on
croit dont on pense aujourd'hui qu'elles
sont possibles même peut-être probable
mais qui aussi peuvent ne pas arriver
donc on ne peut pas là ce n'est pas nous
journalistes qui écrivent en mai
écrivain ou modeste écrivain mais bon
mais l'emporté ouais mais en réalité
précisément dans notre
roman c'est une jeune femme alors
évidemment certains ils verront le
portrait de marion maréchal ce qui n'est
pas le cas
en réalité je pense que la possibilité
je veux dire c'est très rapidement la
possibilité pour ce qu'on appellera
l'extrême droite mais plutôt les
populistes d'arriver au pouvoir
c'est d'abord qu'elle soit cette extrême
droite incarnée par un personnage qui
est plutôt un personnage composite qui
est à la fois politiquement il ya du
mario maréchal ya du robert ménard y ait
du marine le pen il ya du gilbert
collard etc
et nous notre sentiment mais on n'est
pas les seuls puisque robert ménard par
exemple dit lui-même
alors qui est quand même très proche du
rassemblement national
nous nous partons du principe que pour x
raisons marine le pen n'est pas en
mesure peut-être de percer ce plafond de
verre alors que l'extrême droite
pourrait y parvenir mais pourraient y
parvenir à la condition qu'il y ait un
rassemblement qui serait une forme d'
accident de l'histoire
elle y est quand même à la situation
dont on parle depuis une demi heure ici
qui est à la fois crise sociale crise
sanitaire terrorisme etc délitement de
la société scénario c'est celle du
fascisme un moment donné ça se termine
pas ça se termine pas comme ça ça se
termine autrement on va pas ouais pas
donné on va pas spoiler le livre mais on
en n'est protégée aujourd'hui vous
raconter une situation carrément de
l'autocratie un la presse muselée les
syndicats parce que s'est fixés en fait
dans cette inspiré à la fois d'un
certain nombre de discours qui se sont
prononcés par des membres du
rassemblement national voire de
l'extrême gauche car nous pensons que il
s'agit pas d'une alliance électorale au
sommet mais il n'y aura pas d'élection
d'un candidat populiste ou d'une
candidate d'extrême droite sans l'apport
des voix des voix des électeurs
d'extrême gauche d'une partie des
électeurs des électeurs voient bien ce
qui se passe depuis vingt ans notamment
dans le scond a appelé le midi rouge où
l'électorat du parti communiste est
passé avec armes et bagages
du côté du front national donc mais
c'est quelque chose qui est tout à fait
possible et ce que l'on pense également
c'est que dans un système de cette
nature les dérives sont inscrits dans la
nature mer du même du régime
c'est à dire que la dérive populiste et
puis autoritaire policière et finalement
fasciste avec tout ce que ça implique
etc
elle est inscrite dans un mouvement dans
laquelle il ne peut y avoir de marche
arrière que par un véritable une
véritable contre-révolution aussi en
filigrane dans ce livre et ça rejoint
d'actualité le populisme et cette soif
au fond des peuples d'autorité d'hommes
forts ou de femme forte au détriment des
libertés au détriment de la démocratie
ça vous fait peur ça oui oui que enfin
oui oui ça me fait plutôt peur mais en
même temps je pense que au fond vous
savez quand on regarde bien un certain
nombre de cantons dit mais c'est faux
c'est du fantasme c'est un peu n'importe
quoi et c'est enfin il ya énormément de
démocratie dans le monde devraient
démocratie qui ont connu des faces comme
ça de régimes autoritaires voire de
régime fasciste
il ya deux façons pour un régime
autoritaire aux fascistes de s'installer
au pouvoir
le pur coup d'état militaire fait été le
cas au chili de pinochet ça a été le cas
en grèce avec cd vraie démocratie
démocratie chrétienne au chili
démocratie constitutionnelle royauté
constitutionnel en grèce les colonels et
puis il ya la voie électorale et c'est
cela dont on s'est inspirés plus nous
parlons avec notamment ce qui a pu se
passer en italie avec mussolini
on rappelle qu'il était socialiste au
départ je ne parle même pas de
l'expérience interiale c'est à dire que
il ya deux façons
effectivement de balayer la démocratie
de renverser la démocratie soit par un
coup d'état soit par une élection dans
un moment dans un moment c'est toujours
un accident l'histoire mais dans un
moment où on voit bien la conjonction
des crises or nous sommes actuellement
en france dans une conjonction des
crises ion je le dis en action tous les
cinq anticipations
prudent c'est passionnant c'est parfois
un peu effrayant mais allez c'est sli
est vraiment comme un bon polar c'est ça
se termine bien le brun et le rouge avec
michèle cotta chez robert laffont vous
restez avec nous ce qu'il n'est pas de
la fiction c'est ce qui se passe aux
etats unis la compagne et ce duel byden
trumps j - 6 francs soit 6 jours c'est
dingue c'est demain j - site avant les
élections un mec va dire père qui nous
fait vivre chaque soir ce compte à
rebours de quoi nous parle et vous
qu'avez vous retenu dans la campagne
ce qui est important c'est que on
d'abord on n'est pas si - 6 parce que
quand on sera le jour même
75 millions d'américains ont déjà voté
donc ça sera déjà presque terminé mardi
donc c'est déjà une chose à dire la
deuxième chose d'avoir une carte
comment donald trump peut l'emporter en
ayant moins de voix il l'a déjà fait il
ya quatre ans il ya quatre ans il avait
3 millions de voix de moins qu hillary
clinton il a réussi à gagner on regarde
pas les états rouge
ils sont déjà républicains comme le
tennessee on sait que c'est déjà du côté
de trump on va pas les étables eux ils
sont déjà du côté de joe biden va
regarder du côté des états jaune
c'est à dire que le jeu c'est d'aller
chercher les grands électeurs des ces
états qui s'appelle les swing states le
problème de donald trump sur cette carte
c'est qu'il a jamais eu plus de 50%
il n'y a jamais eu plus d'un américain
sur deux qui a été en faveur de donald
trump ça n'est jamais arrivé
alors qu'est ce qu'il lui faut c'est la
campagne secrète il il faut que le vote
soit le plus bas possible
il faut de très très peu de mobilisation
ses patientes et ça passait là bas si ça
va devoir millions mais parce que oui
alors effectivement il ya effectivement
tous ces démocrates qui votent sans
doute quelques républicains aussi mais
il ya aussi 20 millions de dollars
dépensés en frais juridiques pour
empêcher des gens de voter dans certains
comtés notamment les comtés où il ya des
minorités et pour empocher le vote par
la poste est pas notamment nevada ohio
pennsylvanie
c'est vraiment très très important donc
on va voir ce que ça va donner
rien n'est joué pour le moment alors par
contre une petite gaffe
fait il ya encore mais il a dit il a dit
c'était un discours pour les femmes
et c'était pour récupérer de votre
défunt donc il a dit vous inquiétez pas
lakovic ça va être terminé et on va
faire en sorte que vos maris puisse
retourner au travail
sauf que le problème c'est que les
mardis au travail blu ray aux états unis
les femmes aussi elle travaille donc la
polémique en se disant qu'est ce que
c'est que ce président sexistes déjà
parce que déjà joe biden je terminerais
là dessus il a 18 points d'avance chez
les femmes c'est au beurre banal et
femmes de banlieue par rapport à qui pas
par rapport à 30 par rapport il a ri
clinton ya quatre ans c'est à dire que
l'écart c'est les femmes est très
important chez joe biden est encore plus
important qu'il ya quatre ans pour
hillary clinton a encore gagné
je ne sais pas alors là je n'ai pas du
tout les compétences pour le dire je dis
simplement que si trempe l'emportent
c'est vraiment un coup de booster
formidable pour le populisme et les
populistes
ça rejoint ce que nous disions lien
l'instant si trempe est battu je pense
que paradoxalement dans des situations
politiques comme les nôtres aujourd'hui
samaras a sera coup formidable pour les
états unis
ça n'aura pas d'incidence directe sur la
situation électorale qui peut se passer
en france on en déduira pas que le
populisme est mort n'y a pas de loi
directement politique des états unis
outre atlantique a chez nous merci
beaucoup françois à demain on va passer
au décryptage à présent c'est l'autre
événement de la journée la france
s'apprête à rentrer dans son deuxième
dès qu'on fait confinement pardon
qu'elle l'a toujours paris qui se vident
600 km rendez vous compte 600 km de
bouchons en ile-de-france le confinement
qui commence je vous le disais ce soir à
minuit c'est le retour de l'attestation
les députés ont dit oui à la décision d'
emmanuel macron de reconfigurer
totalement le territoire français les
sénateurs ont dit non mais de toutes les
oppositions au sénat comme à l'assemblée
nationale on dénonce un semblant de
démocratie thomas des prêts il était le
monsieur déconfinement le voilà à la
tribune pour défendre leur confinement
du pays sur le président mesdames et
messieurs les députés jean castex homme
de dialogue devant les parlementaires
pour assurer le service après-vente des
annonces présidentielles
un exercice de pédagogie pour tenter de
rassurer les élus de la nation
aujourd'hui il m'appartient de préciser
devant vous tout à la fois les raisons
et les modalités de ces nouvelles
mesures de lutte contre la pandémie d'en
débattre et de vous demander de vous
prononcer trente minutes de discours
durant lesquelles le premier ministre a
rendu des comptes est une représentation
nationale qui s'estiment parfois bafouée
après un simulacre de concertation le
président fidèle à sa politique
verticale du pouvoir annoncé le
confinement
ces mesures sont elles en discussions
n'ont voulu présenter un plan un plan à
prendre ou à laisser
sans un mot sans un amendement possible
nul ligne à gauche les insoumis et une
partie des communistes se sont prononcés
contre la stratégie du gouvernement
les socialistes eux ont voté pour nous
le disent
oui en responsabilité parce que ce qui
est en jeu c'est la santé de nos
concitoyens
et là dessus il peut pas y avoir de
débat première force d'opposition les
députés les républicains ne voulaient
voter contre mais n'ont finalement pas
pris part au vote
après l'attentât de nice qu'aujourd'hui
c'est un temps dans lequel on doit être
rassemblée unie et la hauteur de la
gravité de la situation
à l'annoncé des résultats à la mi
journée voici le résultat
le vote était sans appel mais purement
consultatif 399 députés ont approuvé la
déclaration du premier ministre
27 seulement ont voté contre bonsoir
jean noël barrot
bonsoir merci d'être là vous êtes député
modem des ide les des yvelines et vous
avez voté pour leur confinement ce matin
à l'assemblée vous débattez ce soir avec
mathilde de panneaux bonsoir bonsoir
merci d'être avec nous députés
insoumises du val de marne
vous avez voté contre et bonsoir nathan
peiffer smadja vous êtes infectiologue à
l'hôpital bichat à paris alors on va
commencer avec le volet politique met il
pas ne vous entendiez les socialistes en
responsabilité c'est un vote de colère
mais on vote pour les hôpitaux frôlé la
saturation l'épidémie était hors de
contrôle pourquoi vous être opposé à
cette décision ce matin parce que déjà
plusieurs groupes lent soulignait en
était quasiment dans un vote de
confiance et nous ne faisons plus
confiance à ce gouvernement sur la
gestion de cette épidémie
si nous en sommes arrivés là c'est parce
que depuis huit mois
rien n'a été fait pour préparer la
deuxième vague alors qu'il ya eu de
nombreuses alertes du conseil
scientifique
d'ailleurs dès avril qui a été répété
ans en août en début septembre encore
nous avions à l'époque aussi alerter sur
la seconde vague non pas parce que nous
serions de 20 mais parce qu en écoutant
les scientifiques disent que
généralement dans une épidémie il y à
une première et puis après il ya une
seconde vague on avait alerté sur la
question et dit qu'il fallait absolument
anticiper cette question là et à
l'époque je rappelle que certains nous
ont ri au nez sur cette question là non
réparation lynx et peg votre vélo leurs
responsabilités et la deuxième chose je
crois qui est importante à comprendre
c'est que nous nous avions alerté le
premier ministre à plusieurs reprises
sur cette question de dire il ya des
conditions à mettre en place s'il y a un
recond finement ne nous avons dit
respecteront la discipline sanitaire
mais il n'y aura pas de discipline
sanitaires pour les français et les
françaises s'il n'y a pas des mesures
sociales fortes qui sont prises parce
que des familles qui ont leurs enfants
par exemple qui n'ont pas assez à manger
ou qui n'ont pas à manger comme ça s'est
passé en seine-saint-denis sortiront
dans tous les cas si on avale assurant
que des gestes
il ya des mesures qui ont déjà été
prises peut-être d'autres viendront va
pas faire ce débat là mais moi je
m'intéresse c'est c'est ce qui s'est
passé dans l'hémicycle que vous a
surpris
ce vote compte des insoumis vous avez
évidemment voté pour mais ce se reproche
déjà dû du vote symbolique qui ne sert à
rien mais je crois que c'est devenu un
sport national dans l'hémicycle mais
mais aussi sur certains réseaux sociaux
dans certains médias que de dire que
nous n'avons pas tiré les leçons de la
crise mais ce n'est ces ne pas voir que
cette deuxième vague a pris par surprise
l'europe toute entière alors on peut
évidemment se demander si les dirigeants
de toute l'europe n'ont tiré aucune
leçon de la crise c'est pas du tout
c'est oublier aussi c'est oublier aussi
que la capacité de test a été décuplée
que la capacité de réanimation a été
doublée et qu' il y avait une seule
solution qui s'imposait étant donné les
chiffres alarmants c'était leur
confinement bien le président de la
république aux finances assure sur le
vote qui n'est pas contraignant il ya
d'autres pays
oui mais vous savez quand on avoir
l'aval d'un symbole c'est un autre sport
national qui consiste à dire que le
parlement doit se plaindre pour le
tambour n'ai pas consulté et ea se peler
et ce et critiquer le gouvernement quand
ils consultent le parlement je crois que
c'était important que les annonces
soient présentés en premier lieu à
l'assemblée nationale et au sénat
c'est ce que c'est ce qui s'est passé ce
matin c'est une bonne chose chacun
puisse exprimer et chacun a pu exprimer
son vote
d'abord je le président la veille je
voudrais on va pas vous mettre d'accord
de toute façon c'est vrai qu'il y avait
un vote qui n'avait pas de caractère
contraignant mais qui a été demandé le
vote le vote a eu lieu
qu'est ce qui se passe chez vous à
bichât on dit qu'en moyenne 60%
deux lits sont occupés en caux vide est
ce qu ont frôlé la saturation comment
vous vivez sur le terrain ce qui se
passe oui bah tout à fait vous l'avez
dit comme dans beaucoup d'hôpitaux d'île
de france quand on dit qu'il ya soixante
parfois 70 % des lits qui sont occupées
pour les patients qui ont la même
pathologie à savoir qu vide ça veut dire
qu'on tourne pour les autres patients
qui ont des pathologies extrêmement
grave et qui ont besoin de réanimation
sur 30 % des lits habituel quand on sait
que l'hôpital public
depuis des années on tire la sonnette
d'alarmé dit que on manque de capacité
pour accueillir les gens qu'on manque de
personnel et bien si vous imaginez
qu'aujourd'hui on tourne sur le tiers
des lits de réanimation d'habitude que
dans les hôpitaux et dans les services
de médecine en dehors de la réanimation
parce qu'on en parle un peu moins mais
parfois on a jusqu à 50% nous notre
service et 50% passion comme italien on
tourne sur la moitié des lits habituel
sachant que d'habitude vous re
programmer des opérations non urgentes
déjà on ne la fait pas chirurgie 1 mais
effectivement l'ap-hp le fait et depuis
ça fait ça fait quelques temps la con
reprogrammé en fait que les opérations
de l'urgente parce qu'on a besoin de
lits de réveil donc de réanimation pour
ses opérations et qu'on les a passés lit
et donc nous ça fait des mois qu'on
grignote sur le soin courant des autres
pathologies est donc tous les patients
subissent ça et sont moins pris en
charge et au moins de capacité
d'hospitalisation que d'habitude pour
vous leur confinement est notre affaire
fondamentale problème dure confinement
sais que je peux pas totalement enfin
quand on dit que c'est une surprise
il ya un conseil scientifique en france
ce conseil scientifique où il ya par
exemple arnaud fontanet kern excellent
épidémiologistes ouyahia jeune henry est
en panne à qui mon chef de service ça
fait des mois qu'ils disent que ça va
arriver en octobre en novembre vu les
cinétiques épidémiologique d'autres
épidémies enrichissent de très grands et
pigistes andy je sais pas si vous avez
vu ses courbes de catherine hill qui
montre c'était clair il ya une
augmentation exponentielle
on peut espérer quelque chose de magique
qui réduisent le nombre de cas
maintenant les cas ils augmentent on est
une opération de vous la voulez qu
spectre comment l'accélération brutale
alors derrière de fatalité ça c'est
clair il ya une part de fatalité qui
fait que la les pays européens sont
touchés
après yaya il ya un échec du contact
racing en france on n'est pas capable
aujourd'hui du fait de politiques de
santé publique et de prévention qui sont
extrêmement faibles en france on n'est
pas n'est pas capable de faire comme
taïwan qui contrôle extrêmement bien le
virus oui il ya évidemment des
différences entre
l'asie et l'europe dans le traitement de
cette épidémie en partie parce que
l'asie a connu des épisodes épidémiques
très grave il ya quelques années et à
monter en compétence sur ces sujets
alors que ne peut-être que nous avons
détourné les yeux et peut-être à tort
mais a été bien mais s'agissant de la
stratégie il faut regarder les chiffres
en effet il faut regarder bah non pas du
tout je vous parle de taiwan et du sras
sur le sur le tracé mans sur les têtes
à nouveau je vous dis si vous aussi vous
pensez que c'est un problème français
regarder au delà de nos frontières et
vous verrez que les autres pays
européens qui il est vrai ont pour
certains vu des stratégies différentes
se retrouvent exactement dans la même
situation et si emmanuel macron annoncé
hier leur confinement
la chancelière allemande a fait
exactement le même choix au même moment
robert namias
à qui la faute est ce qu'elle est
légitime cette question simplement voilà
les français se disent on est au même
point
évidemment qu'il faut aider les
soignants qui vont vivre un enfer c'est
pas moi qui le dit c'est frédéric
valette ou et les patients le patron des
hôpitaux
est ce que est ce que c'est c'est
légitime de se poser cette question là
c'est surprenant
à qui la faute d'abord c'est un qui sans
doute qui appellera une réponse beaucoup
plus collective qu'individuelle ou
nominal ça c'est le premier point mais
ça justifie parfaitement quand même et
c'est normal et commission d'enquêté
parlementaire ça c'est vraiment la
démocratie mais il ya une situation
aujourd'hui
et vous parlez vous posez simplement
question du vote d'aujourd'hui à
l'assemblée et au sénat
moi je commence je suis pas du tout un
adepte des sondages ou en tous les cas
ils sont intéressants quand on les
regarde dans la durée et de manière
répétée sur plusieurs plusieurs semaines
ou plusieurs mois mais l'a par exemple
on voit bien que tous les tous les
instituts ont publié en 24 heures
le sentiment l'appréciation le regard
des français sur les décisions annoncées
hier
c'est une écrasante majorité qui les
approuve une écrasante majorité c'est 70
80 % c'est très rare d'avoir une
approbation de cette nature sont tous
pour un pouvoir qui est loupé d'avoir 40
ou 80 % d'approbation par dont les docks
et donc un concert de haut
voit quand même et une fois de plus un
décalage très étrange entre on parle
d'un moment on vote sur une situation à
un moment donné parce euros l'histoire
de l'épidémie depuis quasiment
maintenant un an et donc c'est un
certain baume sur la décision de
confiner le pays totalement ce matin une
chose que je dis donc attention à ce
décalage chef de l'état en matière de
papier
déjà je crois que la première des choses
qu'il faut dire c'est que nous sommes en
démocratie et qui ont démocratie il ya
toujours un autre chemin possible
moi je ne suis pas d'accord pour dire
qu'il n'y a pas d'alternative aux choses
après là c'est comme si on est devant un
ensemble alors au chaud c'est quoi le
bourg le confinement si fou choi les
urgences pardonne pas deux ans
madame panneaux vous me répondez pas le
confinement c'est pas les choses je suis
en train de vous répondre
bon c'est comme lorsqu'il ya un incendie
qu'on nous demande si on va appeler les
urgences ou papier les urgences
évidemment qu'il faut appeler les
pompiers évidemment qu'il faut appeler
les urgences mais la question c'est est
ce que nous faisons confiance pour la
suite de sa large la question il ya une
besoin par exemple de mobilisation
populaire pour prouver entre l'épidémie
il ya une question évidemment auprès des
soignants qui sont épuisés
l'hôpital public est quand même moins
bien préparés maman vous lors de la
première vague obéissent aux médias aux
mesures prises il ya besoin où il n'ya
pas de discipline sanitaires sans
consentement
y'a pas il n'ya pas de discipline
sanitaires sans sa et par exemple sur la
mobilisation populaire qu'est ce qui
empêche le gouvernement de mettre des
assistants d'éducation de prendre les
professeurs sur les attentes de m
d'ouvrir des classes dans des espaces
plus grands pour que les enfants ne se
contaminent pas on va rester sur un plus
petit groupe on va voir ce que ça me
dirait qu'on revienne sur un mètre en
haut de la salle parce que la question
qu'on se pose si le pays fait ça si les
français acceptent ces mesures c'est
pour éviter évidemment des morts et
c'est pour éviter que les soignants ne
soient submergés
nathan peiffer smadja est-ce que la
deuxième vague à l'hôpital tel que vous
vivez et mieux préparés que la première
en terme de lits de réanimation
c'est compliqué je dirais peut-être un
peu clairement c'est pas une différence
majeure qu'on veut convier au jour le
jour après des lits de réanimation ça
effectivement je suis d'accord on peut
pas en faire en six mois et le problème
qu'on a déjà avant même cette crise
c'est que des lits de réanimation il y
en a mais y'a pas d'infirmière
animation il ya combien d'effectifs ils
pouvaient manquer jusqu'à 25% de
l'effectif infirmier
alors bien sûr on a des renforts on a
des gens qui viennent au taux d'à côté
on a des on arrive à mobiliser un peu un
rêve pas rh mais mais parfois n'ont pas
forcément des étudiants mais en tout cas
pour la première vague
là on va voir ce qui va se passer mais
on a réussi à mobiliser dans d'autres
hôpitaux on dit chez ensemble de
références on a eu de l'aide
on a eu de l'aide aussi de la médecine
ambulatoire et des médecins généralistes
mais qui ont été un peu mis de côté lors
de la première vague et là je pense que
on parle de l'hôpital mais il faut
parler aussi de notre réseau de médecine
générale de notre réseau de soin
ambulatoire qui est faible qui est
vraiment faible en france je pense et on
parle deux points on parle de deuxième
vague mais à chaque fois je dis qu'il
faut voir la deuxième vague et tous ces
remous
c'est à dire que il ya la vague des
patients qu'aux vidé puis à la vague
toutes les vagues autour des patients
d'autres pathologies qui ne sont pas
pris en charge
et ça c'est important et la deuxième
chose si on parle beaucoup des soignants
mais je veux dire les soignants moi
depuis que je connais l'hôpital public
je vais pas dire que ça fait 20 ans mais
on est toujours submergées on a toujours
des listes d'attentes nos lits sont
toujours pleins les soignants oui mais
avant tout on le fait pour les patients
et pour les patients qu'aux vide qu'on
doit prendre en charge
et puis pour les patients paco vite
qu'on ne peut plus prendre en charge
donc c'est pour les soignants c'est pour
la zone euro il faudrait 16800
infirmiers supplémentaires pour monter à
12 mai lit on les a pas non et il faudra
évidemment se préparer à des
catastrophes de ceux de ce type là pour
l'avenir il ya eu un premier pas avec le
ségur de la santé ou des décisions ont
été prises à la suite de la première
vague avec des revalorisations avec les
possibilité donnée aux hôpitaux
d'investir avec la formation d'un
certain nombre de d'infirmiers et
d'infirmières techniques de réanimation
mais comme l'a dit monsieur on ne peut
pas former un infirmier réanimateurs en
moins de trois ans on peut pas former un
médecin réanimateur en moins de ceux
plus confuse à léon de dix mots de la
fin le débat s'achève malheureusement
même si le panneau là dessus on est on
est on est au pied du mur il ya eu 7500
lits qui ont été fermés depuis le début
du quinquennat macron il y avait des
soignants qui étaient en grève depuis
plus d'un an avant avant l'épidémie de
coronavirus moi je veux bien qu'on nous
rende tout sur
c'est un mouvement qui remonte à 5 900
millions d'un temps je veux bien qu'on
nous rende tous comptables des décisions
qui ont été prises nous n'avons jamais
été d'accord avec le modèle d'hôpital
entreprises et c'est à cause de ce
modèle dans d'hôpital d'entreprise qu'on
est aujourd'hui dans une situation
catastrophique et un moment le quoi
qu'il en coûte
il faut qu'on le voit en argent et en à
s'arrêter là la réforme de l'hôpital
elle est en cours on la suit de près ici
à la chaîne parlementaire merci à vous
j'ai envie de vous dire bon courage pour
les semaines qui viennent on est de tout
coeur avec vous merci beaucoup
robert namias défient leurs murs de
cette émission très belle soirée sur s&p
et à demain
[Musique]